how's it going everybody it's Warren and
even though Avengers in game is already
out in theaters the hype around it is
very very real and since it's been out
for over a week now there's a lot of
talk and a lot of hype around Marvel's
phase for a lot of people want to know
what the future of the MCU looks like
and what we're going to be getting in
phase four well thanks to the writers of
Avengers infinity war and Avengers
endgame we know that the cosmic entities
are actually in the works of entering
the MCU in an interview with the new
york times screenwriters christopher
markus and stephen mcfeely revealed that
a cosmic entity was actually cut out of
Avengers infinity war they wrote a scene
where the Living Tribunal appeared on
Titan while Thanos was fighting some of
the Avengers ultimately they decided
that it was too much to throw into this
movie or the next movie and would
indicate a whole entire different level
of architecture to the universe so
ultimately they cut the scene out
because they thought it would be too
much however the writers did say that
this is still in Kevin fudgie's ball
court if he wants they use the character
so we almost had the introduction of
cosmic entities in Avengers infinity war
but they decided that it was just too
much however phase four of the MCU we
know is going to explore the cosmic
universe and it actually makes more
sense to introduce The Living Tribunal
now after the events of Avengers
infinity war and Avengers endgame The
Living Tribunal serves as judge over the
universe and all of its realities the
Living Tribunal's job is to oversee and
maintain balance over the universe and
its realities and that is exactly why
they were going to have the Living
Tribunal show up and Avengers Infinity
Ward because Stannis was threatening
reality he was threatening the universe
and it's balance now again he didn't
show up but after the events of infinity
war with the snap and the events of
Avengers in game undoing the snap and
doing another snap combined with the
Avengers going back in time and creating
multiple alternate realities the
universe is kind of thrown out of whack
right now and now with a new phase of
the MCU starting they don't have to
introduce the Living Tribunal and cosmic
entities all at once they can gradually
introduce them over time because again
the reason they didn't introduce the
Living Tribunal and Avengers in game was
because ultimately they decided that it
was just too much to throw in with
everything going on all at once but now
they can build it up and there are
probably multiple cosmic entities that
would have a problem with what Thanos
and the Avengers did especially because
phase 4 in the MCU moving forward is
going to explore the cosmos so now it's
the perfect opportunity to introduce the
cosmic entities with time to build them
up and not to mention that Disney now
owns the rights to Galactus of course he
will not be introduced right away he's
somebody that needs time to build up
much like they did Thanos but Marvel had
plans to introduce the cosmic entities
in Phase three
they did it and now it looks like it's
on the table for phase four and a good
possibility especially since the writers
of infinity war and endgame said that
the Living Tribunal character is in the
president of Marvel Studios Kevin Feige
ball court
so Marvel wants to introduce the cosmic
entities they almost did it in Phase
three and now it's looking like we're
going to see it happen in phase four but
let me know your thoughts on this let me
know what you think about them leaving
The Living Tribunal out of Avengers
infinity war and Avengers in game and
about the future possibility of him
coming along with the rest of the cosmic
entities let me know your thoughts in
the comments down below if you liked the
video give it a like and don't forget to
subscribe to my channel so you can stay
up to date on all things relating to the
future of the MCU and all things
superhero as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof
congratulations to your desperation to
save the universe you killed half of its
population yeah you did it very nice and
all it took
you said it cost you everything while
crying like a baby now your